[Música]
[Aplausos]
eis aqui uma filha de família rica
tradicional que só um sofre o impacto de
ter nela uma mãe solteira eu tinha 22
anos quando nenhum rótulo mãe solteira
parece que as pessoas esquecem tudo que
você foi até ali e você está fadada a
viver pelo resto da sua vida o que é
aquele estereótipo te trouxe foi assim
que eu me senti uma família linda tem um
privilégio eu não mais velho e meu irmão
caçula de termos pais maravilhosos que
dedicaram e dedicam sua vida pra ter uma
família feliz
uma família de ponta retrato e aí eu me
perguntava 'será 21 22 anos já formada
em publicidade e propaganda de uma
notícia dessa é mesmas os assustadora
com a família
sim foi assustador para a minha família
especialmente para mim ser mãe sempre
foi um sonho de criança ea gente brinca
de boneca né as mulheres nós somos
acostumados com a maternidade desde
muito cedo mas essa hora sem planejar ea
notícia o eliana está grávida
questionava a validade de uma outra
forma bem acompanhada do poliana não é
casada recebia aquele exame e aquele
impacto bem junto com uma coragem que eu
nunca imaginei perder e queria ter uma
coragem que me acompanha até hoje mas a
primeira
são admito nós mulheres também somos
fadados a ter medo medo de barata tem
medo de casar ter medo de não casar tem
medo de ser empreendedora tem medo de
não ser vendedora e por ainda sim eu
estava muito medo mas eu estava com uma
coragem que me levou a ser aprenderá a
encarar e eu vou falar com o meu pai
como a mãe sozinha na hora de contar
respirei fundo e fui pai é um homem
maravilhoso toda une toda agora a
história dele com o impacto da notícia
ser esperada para mim imagina pra ele
pegou e falou o seguinte você tá marcado
igual o gato
homem nenhum mais deve respeitar não
tinha falta de amor daquela frase tinha
um medo
mais uma vez o medo eu escutei pela
frase e gravei entre outras
mas aquela me marcou uma mania vi
lágrimas também tinha uma frase para
mudar minha vida minha filha acabou com
a sua profissão
agora você vai passar o resto da sua
vida em casa cuidando de filhos também
não faltou à urna até análise também
tinha um medo ela tinha medo da minha
história
repetir a história dela você já ouviu
aquela frase do veneno está ativo
foi essa frase que me trouxe até aqui
hoje essas duas pessoas que mais me
deram a mão na vida estavam
decepcionados
eu cometo e eu peguei aqui e falei
comigo mesmo
eu não sei
enquanto eu não curar o medo dos meus
pais são amantes de deus então diretora
eu me senti no direito de pedir uma
coisinha
sempre sonhei em ter filho a menina
boneca assim trocar de roupa e uma
menina que eu soube que o meu bebê é meu
enviado de deus
gabriel o dia o mundo me respeitar
mas eu tinha talvez no mundo com um
homem que mais tem que me respeitar
muito o motivo do medo de virar isso
mais uma vez e deu força
trabalhei do início ao fim da gravidez
também tirando medo da minha mãe eu não
parei
eu não parei do dia que eu soube com jô
e até um dia antes de ter o joel e
quatro dias antes de ter o campeão eu
mudei de médico teve então de novo
méxico que o médico que fez o pré natal
que uma cesariana
até então o formado em publicidade e pós
graduado em marketing out efe agência de
publicidade consultor em marketing e eu
era tudo na minha agência
bombril nenhuma utilidade e eu não podia
arrastar um resguardo demorado
rezemos toté compreendido da sul
e eu falei assim meu deus eu vou
arriscar uma cesariana e isso não
conseguir libertar daquela trama em
cuidar do meu filho
a única coisa que eu pedi pra mim o
primeiro momento seu primeiro lugar
queria te procurar o abrigo eu segurar
eu fazer dormir e eu aumentar e deus
mais uma vez de um carro
eu tive um parto lindo um parto natural
metros do reboleira foi dentro d'água
numa casa de quarto atendida pelo sus
mesmo tendo condição de escolher as
melhores maternidades de belo horizonte
e optar com a maioria das mulheres optam
por cesariana e eu tive medo mesmo
porque eu tinha um sentido maior detalhe
e assim que eu peguei na banheira de
água e ele trouxe ele para o meu colo
olhei pra ele ea outra coisa que eu
consegui dizer nós conseguimos dar ali
nascia oficialmente a poliana uma mãe do
gabriel e mais vários desafios
mas como eu aprendi com ele e como ele
vencido até onde e como mãe consegue ter
tanta coragem através disso e essa
coragem que me fez cumprir uma outra
promessa metal
eu falei eu me deu o prazo de até cinco
anos de idade eu está morando
só eu e ela ainda namorava com os meus
pais e meu irmão a quem agradeço a todo
acolhimento e todo amor durante esses
cinco anos de trabalho para o vale do
aço face ao final de semana porque até
hoje um mês de trabalho trabalho é fazer
o mesmo com sabedoria e aqui fiquei era
a oportunidade que eu tinha de cumprir
aquela minha promessa
o primeiro ano 2009 foi bem desafiador
branco em belo horizonte eu ficava aquém
de terça a sexta e aí eu vi que não é
natural uma mãe que aonde já se viu que
seja quatro dias da semana em 2010
trouxe o gabriel para cá e aí
oficialmente eu era mãe e pai de família
de gabriel era um deles
vim de família foi me mata um sabe
entender o que ela achava que a trama
estende as duas mortes
tinha que tive que aprender chegar ao
supermercado tentar ficar acordo que era
fácil
um dia tive eu sempre o dom de comunicar
então isso me ajudou e ele no domingo o
campeão desde que nasceu com dois dias
de parida já estava trabalhando porque
ele antecipou a chegada e eu precisava
acaba de editar o vídeo para o cliente e
ele foi comigo sempre amamentei
trabalhei e ele sempre me acompanhou o
meu filho sempre acompanhou meu trabalho
e ele sempre admirou meu trabalho porque
ele não conhecer outra realidade e isso
me tornou mais segura mas vinha sempre
medo e um sentimento de culpa culpa olha
só é mãe solteira atraso e na gráfica de
gabriel muito não vinha fazendo uma
campanha política trouxe mãe sentadinho
para todo mundo 70 fez um jingle para
mim a entrada de ivo sabe o que era o
xodó do livro fazia cabaninha de
fotolito graça quando eu precisava
trabalhar até mais tarde e para as
outras pessoas
tá vendo é porque mãe solteira que fosse
meu filho não é o sofrimento
aí 2014 teve uma queda de rendimento
profissional
para falar a verdade eu estava quebrada
mesmo ea iminência de voltar para belo
horizonte
mais uma vez eu tive medo medo porque eu
ia deixar de
cumprir a minha promessa do meu pai e da
minha mãe e do meu filho o que falar do
tal de coaching na época não saberem
falar essa palavra entrei no curso de
final de semana de imersão coaching
eu falei vou ver que esse tranco e fui
lá mandou inteira por falar de sumo e de
propósito de autoconhecimento e de lá
que cê tá aqui nesse mundinho
olha só eu tô aqui pra tirar o medo do
meu pai e da minha mãe do meu filho e eu
estou aqui pra que as pessoas nem foi aí
que eu entendi o que é ter sonhos e mais
do que as versões
eu queria me treinar liga capacitar pra
realizar sonhos e realizações também me
trouxe até aqui foi uma jornada de
autoconhecimento e de muito amor
até eu me tornar resgatando um quadro os
meus nas intimações
eu queria ser uma mãe já era eu queria
ser uma empreendedora é mais aquela
história de que eu vou ficar em casa
cuidando de si
respeitar o papa deixa pra lá eu vou
realizar meus sonhos e aí em 2015 e me
tornei um empresário do mercado de
varejo realizando o sonho de uma
franquia que eu sou apaixonada desde os
14 anos e ele estranha de realizar sonho
realmente me envolvem gabriel mais uma
vez do meu lado e agora eu já estava
casada tirar o título de mãe solteira e
esse negócio de realização vai trazer do
outros
e a gente está envolvendo tudo isso traz
empreendedora mais governo que eu tive
medo
foi então eu descobri que olha que
gostoso um medo pra mim é uma boa
professora eliene joga pra sair pra
frente joga pra frente e me faz crescer
me faz agir como eu amo ter medo como eu
amo ser uma mulher com medo porque é
esse meu medo que me faz ter coragem
aquela coragem descobrir dentro daquele
exame de gravidez e que me trouxe até
aqui
mas a língua coragem também nenhum
sentimento de culpa que carregou com
muito tempo
a culpa não seja teve uma família dona
jata e aquela culpa nem sempre era da
sociedade afirmou
essa mente brilhante e essa conta
bancária com até o dia que eu resolvi me
livrar dela
mesmo com medo após uma semana de
viagens a trabalho
um amiga falou o símbolo de campeão
sozinho você trabalha muito e percebi
felicidade do meu filho mas manda lá
conferindo com ele na cama
se minha vida
se você tivesse uma marca uma varinha de
condão aqui agora uma baixa e pudesse
mudar alguma coisa na mãe que mudaria
já fechei o olho a trabalhar - disse
realmente é um dos meus sonhos tratar
aí eu peguei e fui mais fundo e achou
que ia falar que era trabalhar - de água
e respondeu ah mãe mais feliz
e aí acabou minha culpa eu lembrei
estados mas a deus já ouvi na vida do
doutor joão gabriel foi meu pediatra
uma vez me disse filho que a mãe feliz
com essa história o ramo e respeitando a
história com medo e sem culpa e com
muita coragem coragem de instalar as
mulheres as mães sejam casadas solteiras
se tem medo medo mesmo que é o medo que
a gente cria coragem de uma mãe com
ontem de dados ou mesmo respeitando uma
profissional muito feliz
há muito que eu faço eu ou não ser mãe
eu amo ser pronta empreendedora e eu
tenho bastante
teza que todas nós mulheres
mesmo cheio de medo mesmo com culpa que
eu não tenho mais
temos a coragem de realizar sonhos e de
ter dentro da gente um pontinho de muita
força que nos faz ter ações pra ser
começou feliz todos os dias
obrigada obrigada